we got Ricky Wilson got Simon Rick's and
from the Kaiser Chiefs in the studio
this morning and everybody knives so
familiar with Ricky and as the judge one
of the judges there on the voice but
nice going back to his day job there's a
new album aight i came out yesterday and
it's called education education
education and war that's true and more
that's a bit that's a bit of a long one
there is a bit of a mouthful we shot
ourselves in the foot without a little
bit considering Twitter and all that yes
too many characters and run down to the
charts yeah about seven is education
education education and war it's like to
juice like two for the price of one it's
a mouthful but i think it's 'rememorable
is that one memorable memorable I'm what
what is it a biopsy man why that title
question asked from being Ricky that
really it's what the lyrics are about
really i think it's we went through a
lot of difficult times last year and we
learnt a lot of new things and we were
sort of had a bit of conflict within the
band then we had some things to prove
and I think we thought we were the
underdogs and we were like fighting so
we sort of thought it's awesome zup what
the album's about really and also it's
got a little bit of you know political
poking so you're back fighting is what
you're saying really you hopefully you
use her back after a bit of died a bit
of for like maybe is jeopardy jeopardy
it's the best where we most comfortable
to be honest we're not really happy
unless with fine aware of a corner and
being a bit more of the underdog yeah so
I'm not saying I don't to sell those
records um I think it's right under
there you go yeah so a band member lost
left the Kaiser Chiefs how different is
this album going to be then without him
well we had to try a lot harder because
we knew we had to be twice as good as we
thought we could be in order to to carry
on doing what we love doing and we
didn't want to give up and we want to do
this as long as possible and it's
something that we remembered was worth
fighting for and this is the new single
and this week and it's called calming
holden astra chan any significance in
that yeah i mean what choosing the first
single is always difficult that this one
we wrote in the rehearsal room we've
been rehearsing in for the last
10-15 years and it really felt like not
just a physical coming home but we were
getting back to where we thought it
belonged okay well let's let's sit back
and have a listen
you have stayed on
you wanna go
Jana
well
so much to talk about death from seeing
that and the biggest thing that leap
site is and a lot of people think that
you know pop bands that they're well off
they've got a lot of money to throw
around and you know instead you look at
Ricky there and it's the same shirt yeah
I really should have thought this
through soon they're filming that's what
you should say I should have said that
but everything else is in the wash where
was that one shot hey said near
harrogate in Leeds Yorkshire Moors so
it's sort of very very much coming home
for us yeah it was so hard by garden
yeah okay Simon couldn't ask you and
when Ricky Stein doing the voice do you
guys come and visit them did you pop
down there and have a look and see what
that's about her what do you make of his
foray into show business like I've
anyone taken a step I'm hoping to go off
64 last one I saw today so hopefully go
to that book always been some of it we
were busy for the rest of those men I've
always watched job though and I like
it's good you when you're judging on the
voice coaching on the whole shape sorry
that's what that's what I line inside to
talk when you're coaching how much do
you think about the guys in the band
when you're making decisions do you
think they're gonna give me grief of
this or me when I'm making decisions do
i think i don't think about them at all
totally about your room totally it's all
me me me i'm not really really nervous
why do i was reading the papers just
you're given prescriptions you give me
you know have you drunk I didn't know
what it was okay they gave me some
seasickness tablets it's a doctor well I
didn't know what it was and I was just
dizzy and I went to a doctor summary
dizzy and he goes that's anxiety you
know I'm not anxious about something as
he goes well what you're doing at the
moment so I'm gonna do this TV show but
writing an album and flying back and
forth from USA and you know oh this is
up this is something you guys I society
mate but yeah parently so what intervals
are you anxious to I should if there's a
new series will you see you back you've
got five seconds definitely I don't know
I've no idea thank you very much